Speaker 1: I want to play some clips
for you of Jim Jordan. Jim Jordan is
a Republican congressman. And Jim Jordan is
interesting because he is sort of the epitome
of the I say a lot of stuff, but when it comes
down to it, I don't really stand behind the
principles. And when it comes to Jim Jordan, often
those principles have to do with small government
conservatism, so-called small government
conservatism. And the claim from the right that,
oh, we don't want to regulate. We don't we want to
let businesses do what they want to do. Jim Jordan
appeared last night no, the night before last with
Sean HANNITY. And he seems to be saying here that
Apple should be investigated because they've
stopped advertising on Twitter. That's pretty.
That's pretty. That's several levels deep when it
comes to getting pretty involved in the decisions
made by private businesses. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 3: I think there's some other critical
question, Sean, we've got to ask, like, why did
Apple change the features on phones in China?
Why do that for the CCP? And I think the other
the other key point here is why why is Apple no
longer advertising on Twitter knowing that some of
their ads have they gone wild? So what I want to
know is, where was the apple? Where's the apple
that a few years ago said, we're going to stand
up for Americans privacy? Where's the Tim
Cook? Who told Jim Comey, there is no way
we're giving the FBI backdoor access to people's
phones. That's the apple we want to see. Because,
again, right now we know one thing, Sean. The
left is at war with the First Amendment. The
left doesn't want the First Amendment anymore.
And that is that is the key concern here. The
left now says this. If you don't agree with
them, you're not allowed to speak. And if you.
Speaker 1: Think about how crazy that is,
you look. These are people. Who want to tell
businesses you're pulling advertising from
Twitter because you don't like Elon Musk. We
should investigate that. That's their free speech,
right? Those businesses have the right to express
themselves by advertising or not advertising
wherever the hell they want. And they have the
gall and the audacity to say it's the left that's
against speech. Understand that all of these
actions being taken by people related to Twitter
are protected by free speech. If someone wants
to protest Elon Musk's ownership of Twitter by
quitting Twitter, that is their constitutionally
protected free speech, right? Whether it's because
they're woke or not doesn't really matter. If
you want to lobby companies that you patronize to
stop advertising on Twitter because you don't like
Twitter, that's your free speech, right? If I see
that, you know, whatever, what company, you know,
frameworks is advertising on Twitter. And I want
to go to frameworks and say, hey, you shouldn't
advertise on Twitter because of this. That the
other thing. That's my my free speech. Right. And
if Gator works frameworks are gator frameworks.
This is my mic stand. If Gator Frameworks says,
oh, we want to ignore what our customers
are saying and keep advertising on Twitter,
that's their right. And if they say that's
that's kind of an interesting idea. Yeah, maybe
our word. But some of our customers are right. We
shouldn't advertise on Twitter. That's also their
free speech, right? This is all speech. And they
claim it is the left that is suppressing speech.
These people are pathetic. And by the way, this
we should they should be worried if they start
investigating Apple, what will happen with all
of the investigations into Hunter Biden that they
have planned? One other clip from this appearance
two nights ago, continuing to talk about Twitter.
Speaker 2: Take Twitter off the App Store. That's
all that is good news there. Is it maybe because
Elon Musk threatened to compete with with Apple.
Speaker 3: Yeah, well, I probably sell,
but it sounds like that meeting went well
today. Let's move. We'll find out tomorrow.
So let's hope they're not going to kick
Apple out of the App Store. But I think.
Speaker 1: They're. Imagine if ten years ago,
even eight years ago, I told you in 2022, almost
2023 Republicans are going to be on Fox News doing
segments wherein they say, hey, you know what, we
got to make sure that Twitter doesn't get kicked
out of Apple's App Store. And if they do, we might
just have to investigate that. These people,
they're truly something else. It's all small
government. It's all small government. Make sure
that you are subscribed to the YouTube channel at
YouTube.com slash The David Pakman Show. We're
going to take a quick break and be back right
after this. The David Pakman Show depends on your
support. We are a viewer, listener, community,
audience supported program. We make it very,
very easy to support the work we do. You just go
to join Pacman Qcom. That's really it. It's
simple, it's quick, it's easy and you can use
the coupon code. 24 starts now. 24
starts now to get yourself a discount